- Leadership, and that.
You know what's funny, I think this is
like the cliche Wednesday
after Labor Day, right?
Like, today it's fucking real.
You know what I mean?
♫ We're unstoppable
(inspiring music)
Just got out of, Babbet, you
got some of that footage?
- I got it.
- Yeah, just got out of
the leadership meeting.
Tom.
Got out of the leadership meeting,
bunch of the leaders got a lot done,
grounded, super excited about kind of
getting the fourth quarter underway.
Everybody kind of updated the rest
of the leadership team
on where they're going,
how they're going about it.
And I enjoyed it, really productive.
- [Lady] Hi!
- [Gary] Okay.
- [Employee] I've been
texting you about this.
There's a dex, the event--
- Yes.
- There's a ton of dropoff
after three seconds,
is the event really on--
- The ton of drop off after 30 seconds
based on videos that are
longer than 30 seconds.
There's a lot of fascinating little games
being played in the digital world,
I know Facebook's doing this,
the video was 33 seconds,
and the drop off happened at 30 seconds.
Do you know what I mean?
I almost feel like I
wanna write this deck,
you know how I do it?
Hey, I know I've gotten everybody
in love with long form, and that is
been some of our special source.
Sauce, but that's not in leu of short,
and there's a lot of
data supporting short.
- Well, and here's the thing--
- Is that right, right?
- Second from the video too.
- Great news, we just fucking filmed it.
- Yeah.
- Vayner Media.
I'm being dead serious, Vayner Media,
I'm sending you a deck right now,
this is the attached video.
- [Announcer] A few moments later.
- Have an awesome day.
So, series of productive
meetings off the bat.
What's the early theme of the day?
Leadership, you know what's funny?
I think this is like the cliche Wednesday
after Labor Day, right?
Like, today it's fucking real.
You know what I mean?
Like today, there's a lot
of fucking people around.
Like it got real, real fast.
We're here in Long Island City,
in the new Vayner Media Office,
and studio, 50,000 square feet of video
and audio producing and running counts of.
I'm gonna go work.
How you guys doing?
All good?
Hey.
- [Assistant] So we're
gonna get you into wardrobe.
- Amazing.
I don't know if I can have this.
I've done this exact talk on the road,
in these places, this is what I've done.
- [Director] We're gonna say it
and send it directly to them.
- I've been to Buffalo,
I've been to Foxborough.
And by the way, they
don't even play in Boston,
they play in a shit
city called Foxborough.
I just came out of makeup,
they told me I was beautiful.
But not beautiful enough,
but now I'm ready, looks like
they're setting up.
It's super weird that Vayner Productions
is filming me, we're on
the actual talent in shot,
so this is unusual, this is the first time
I've been excited about it.
It's triple meta.
We've got Ubab in here.
Own Vayner Production up in one.
And it's very, very.
- [Director] And wear it backwards!
- And they're like my friends?
- [Director] They're your buddies.
- All right, friends.
- [Director] And tunnel guys, quiet.
- Scene one, take one, mark.
- Here see.
Let's be honest, nobody cares that you
actually play in New York,
because we don't like unlovable losers.
Here's to you.
No level of success is gonna hide
a profoundly uncool UR.
Sorry about that.
- [Director] Okay
resetting, still rolling.
- What?
- [Director] Profoundly.
- What I say?
- [Director] Profounding.
- Got it.
- [Director] Okay, settle everyone.
- Your way?
That's not good.
- [Director] Resetting, still rolling.
- Super excited so far.
There's my production team.
There's the Vayner Productions team,
really enjoying working with them,
excited about where Vayner
Productions is going.
Working with clients, working
with a bunch of you guys.
You need film-work, we're the gang.
We're the fellas, we're the gals.
Yeah, we need to take a, of me sitting.
We're gonna make a
display, cardboard display,
and then we're gonna build it
inside of my library and
run the video on the TV's.
Do an event again.
- Never go, but I need to go.
Last time I tried to go you told me
to go to his family's
for (mumbles) (laughs).
- That sounds true.
Tyler just got fired, guys.
Breaking news, Tyler Schmitt, fired.
For trying to sell liquor to his family's
Mount Clare store which I respect.
- A move that I think--
- Which I respect.
There's a move picked up for me,
only to be your own demise.
Listen, it was fun to have him around.
Remember Tyler Schmitt, we was a good.
- [Lady] He got fired.
- Yeah, he just got fired,
but it was really, he had a great.
Don't fuck with me.
He had a great run, fired.
- What's going on, man, how you doing?
- [Gary] Hey man, how are you?
- Good.
- [Gary] It's a real pleasure.
- How you doing?
- [Gary] Yeah, thanks for doing this.
- No problem, man.
- [Gary] Happy to connect.
You well?
- I'm very well.
- [Gary] Good.
- Yeah, I'm happy, my
cousin sent it to me.
You too, and I was like, ah cool.
Check it out, see what's going on.
- [Gary] Where do you live?
- Jersey City.
- [Gary] Oh yeah?
I love it, I grew up in Edison.
- Oh yeah, I did a little research,
I actually never heard of you before.
- [Gary] Well I appreciate
it, now, nice to
make your acquaintance, man.
- Yeah, yeah, I was like,
all right, Jersey Guy.
- Let us know if there
is anything we can do.
- Yeah, cool.
- Enjoy it, real pleasure,
thank you for doing it, my man.
Take care of yourself, say what's up
to your president.
- I will.
- Please?
- Definitely.
- Yeah, it's super important for you to
leave the part where he says,
I didn't know who you were.
'Cause you guys need to know that 99%
don't know exactly who I am.
That's the exactly the best part
of this whole fucking thing.
All of you worry about it making it
and this and that, you
never fucking make it.
This is a fucking struggle for everyone.
You never make it.
You're always grinding.
Bye guys, take care.
We should do a meet up right in here.
YouTube, what do you guys think?
Meet up, right in here,
show them, Bad Man.
We're gonna drop it
somewhere in the winter,
we're gonna do a meet
up, like a late night,
just do a fucking party.
Will we get arrested?
(pop music)
♫ I will follow
♫ I'll follow you
♫ Deep sea baby
We wanted to use this
as a prospecting event
for the advisory board, right?
Is that how you heard of it?
Okay.
- Gary!
- How are you?
I need all the content support.
I need an Instagram story,
I need a Facebook campaign.
- I would say an office in Chattanoonga
is what I'm most interested in.
- Okay.
Just had an interview with Mickey Clouds,
been here for a while.
Good dude.
Runs our Chatanoonga office.
I'm a fan.
Just a strategic talk about the office,
the offerings, the opportunities.
The good, the bad, the ugly.
Also met with Kim Garcia
from Vayner Experience,
our events business is exploding,
4D is what a lot of you guys know about,
got a wine event that
we're gonna be doing,
some other events that we're rolling with,
so just a lot of good shit going on.
Now meeting with an old friend.
Cool!
Fun day.
What was really fun part of the day is,
I was doing some content for a client.
The multiple takes I have to take
when I'm not in control of the verbiage
made me laugh.
(laughs)
All those different takes,
I don't know how Bavvin's gonna edit it
was super funny, but really just
enjoying the action of the city right now,
headed to the US Open with a client,
be fun to get a little tennis action in.
See one of the all time
greats do his thing,
Roger Federer, a lot of respect for him,
even though I'm a Djoker fan.
And just really glad to
be back in the grind,
and back with you guys,
really just miss you guys a lot.
Now headed to catch
downtown in New York City,
to hang out with one of my favorites.
You'll see.
♫ Only her, only him.
Distribution.
- Absolutely.
- Period.
- Realest of real things.
Streams to reality.
Everything we fucking
think about comes true,
so be fucking careful.
- Don't scare them.
- About who you offend,
because if you offend me,
I'm gonna think about your demise, bitch!
(Gary laughs)
- This hat is bitching.
- [Assistant] Yeah, it is. (laughs)
- [Director] All right, here we go.